united kingdom has given approval to a
trial that will expose
healthy volunteers to covert 19.
infection is guaranteed with a so-called
challenge trial challenge trial
challenge trial
as the pandemic progressed over the last
year you may have heard this term
challenge trial come up the idea was
that by deliberately exposing people to
the virus you could help speed up the
development of a vaccine
and it turns out a lot of people were up
for this you know everybody feels
terrible right now
here's something that may help the world
be a little bit better
so i was like great that sounds good to
me um let me sign up right now
ultimately challenge trials did not end
up being used to develop the vaccines
that are now in circulation
but now researchers in the uk are
turning to the challenge method saying
it will allow them to test the long-term
effectiveness of the vaccines
and learn more about the disease overall
it's restarted a controversy in the
scientific community over the safety
efficacy and morality of the practice i
spoke to some very smart people on both
sides of the argument
in an attempt to answer a question with
big implications for humanity's future
okay so we're here to talk about human
challenge trials but i guess first let's
talk about typical vaccine trials how do
typical vaccine trials work yeah so once
a vaccine candidate has been studied in
animals and in the laboratory it moves
into human
studies the idea is that once you're
vaccinated with either
a placebo of the actual candidate you're
exposed in
society to the pathogen and we want to
see that most of the infections
and disease occurred in people with the
placebo to determine that the vaccine is
actually protective and efficacious
so with a human challenge study we
deliberately
infect humans human volunteers
and look at essentially what happens to
them
you say i've got the viral agent covid
whatever it is
and i'm going to give it to people this
is art kaplan he's a researcher at nyu
who's pretty firmly in the pro
challenge trial column well historically
vaccines are tested
in large trials usually you're talking
30 40 50
60 000 or more subjects you could spend
six seven eight years trying to get data
the challenge study
basically is a way to speed up the trial
process
you may be able to get answers as
quickly as exposing 500
600 people maybe over a period of six
months to a year
so are human challenge trials new or
have they been done before
human challenge trials are not new um
scientists have been doing them for
quite a long time decades looking at
various diseases
malaria cholera influenza
are some of them walter reed did it as a
matter of fact with his malaria
experiments in cuba they deliberately
let mosquitoes bite them to get malaria
to test
antidotes assuming they again they want
to kill you although people have died in
challenge studies
we have a tradition in space medicine of
saying
gee i wonder how long people can survive
extreme
gravitational forces let's put them in a
centrifuge until they pass out
so there are many areas of medicine
healthcare
even public health where we do expose
people to risk
deliberately in order to learn
[Music]
this is the infamous trolley problem in
bioethics which is
should you sacrifice one person to say
five five people this is liza dawson the
chief of bioethics at the walter reed
army institute of research
she's not really opposed to challenge
trials but where covet is concerned
she's basically in the ante column
one of the issues is that we have less
ability to predict what will happen to
people
as a consequence of covet infection
something like 10 to 20 percent or
depending on the numbers
have long-term consequences of covet
infection that's not to be sneezed at
and people of all ages seem to be um
susceptible
to longer term consequences of covid we
are rolling the dice
that something terrible might happen or
something you know
fairly bad might happen to people in
these trials well i do understand the
critics
and some of their points of view you
know it's never easy to defend
deliberately giving someone
something that makes them sick that
violates sort of a core
norm of medical ethics do no harm but
i'm not really
buying into the uh it causes more harm
to do a challenge study it feels
psychologically different to give
somebody a disease
as opposed to saying gee i don't know
how you got it maybe it was on the
subway or maybe you should have worn a
mask or
maybe a new variant appeared we may feel
you know psychologically we didn't do it
nature did it
nonetheless at the cemetery they don't
care
you're relying on nature to infect you
but it's not like people aren't exposed
i'm not sure that that's significantly
morally better
than just saying i'll give you the
disease and we'll get a faster answer
and there are a lot of volunteers who
feel the same way the organization one
day sooner which advocates for people's
right to participate in challenge trials
says it's had almost forty 000 people
contact them offering to take part if
such a trial were to be conducted
two of those volunteers are lena
jeweller a recent graduate of johns
hopkins
and gabrielle kleinwacks a phd student
in colorado
safe to say they're both in the pro
column
so speaking personally why would you be
willing to be part of a challenge trial
i think you know initially i was looking
at this kind of
as a person who does human subjects
research and a person who
likes to participate in human challenge
research so one of the cool things about
being a student at hopkins
is that you have access to participate
in this like really cool research
and i've always found that fascinating
um you know just as a person to
participate to say okay i'm contributing
to this science that
may you know help someone else down the
road and then the challenge aspect of it
i was really swayed by this like
argument of like we can like this is so
much more efficient this is so much more
effective
i would say the very first place my mind
went
was so i'm jewish um and in our
philosophical traditions it said that to
save a single life
it's as if you've saved an entire world
in the argument for child trials the
original argument back in march
it was estimated that developing a
vaccine every day sooner that you
develop a vaccine
saves 10 000 lives
and i thought that that's amazing i
would do whatever it took to develop a
vaccine
one day sooner which is why why the
organization is called that
we all know what it means to donate your
time we all know what it means to donate
your money
but this was an opportunity i felt to to
donate health to try to share some of my
health
with others so there are reasonable
arguments on either side of the ethics
debate and a lot of people are willing
to take the risk
but some offer a different kind of
criticism of challenge trials
that they wouldn't actually accomplish
their goal of speeding up vaccine
development
that's the big beef put forward by
charles vare a canadian bioethicist
he says the current uk study is the
perfect example of just how long
challenge trials can take what they're
doing so they've
spent a number of months developing the
challenge strain
so making sure they've got a stable
strain where they haven't
introduced mutations through the
manufacturing
process the second step is what they're
just embarking on now
it's actually figuring out the protocol
for how they're
going to administer this virus and so
we're just beginning that process
now with incremental steps of increasing
dose of virus
each of those steps is going to take at
least a month
and so we're many months away
from them being at at the point where
they can even
test test vaccine advocates of challenge
studies by
and large haven't talked about all this
preparatory work that needs to be done
even from the first article that was
published about this they sort of talked
as if you know sort of next week we
could just start doing this right you
just
pump a room full of cover 19 and then
yeah everybody gets right
and of course these studies are are much
more
complicated uh than that and then
there's the fact that we got the current
slate of covet 19 vaccines in record
time
without using challenge trials the
reason
why we got a vaccine so quickly
was because of a decade worth of work
on related coronaviruses that caused
sores
and that caused mers and i think we had
the genome of sars kov2 the the novel
coronavirus published
on january 10th i think of 2020.
three days later we had our first
candidate vaccine 63 days later that
vaccine was tested for the first time in
human beings
by september of last year we had
six large phase three trials planning to
involve
280 000 people the the monumental size
of the achievement here
it would be difficult to overstate well
that's traditional vaccine development
with new technology and it just
highlights my point
challenge studies are just are just the
wrong
technology for a rapidly moving
pandemic
but some still see challenge trials
playing a crucial role in the pandemic
ironically precisely because we now have
working vaccines
as soon as things start to look very
promising we basically are in a
situation where those people who are in
a large scale trial let's just use
covin are going to start to say wait a
minute i don't want to be in the placebo
group anymore
i want to drop out and you can't finish
the study ethically you've got to let
those people know
you're in the placebo group you can be
pretty certain that nearly everybody
will drop out because
they're not going to hang around in the
placebo group are very likely
so the studies that we have undergoing
that are underway now
of covid vaccines are falling apart
because people are dropping out of them
left and right
and so we're not going to get answers
that we might want the things like how
long does this vaccine
last in terms of protection or do we
know whether it's protecting us against
new variants of the
virus that appear some also see
challenge trials as a path to developing
new vaccines that improve on the
existing ones
obviously at this point we've got
approved vaccines in the us and and
maybe eight or nine total globally
but there's still a lot of benefit to
these sorts of trials
we can expand the total pool of how many
different types of vaccines we have
available and that's important because a
lot of the vaccine candidates we have
now like the mrna vaccines they're hard
to transport
they take two doses all these things
that if we
continue to try new vaccines we can find
better vaccines that are easier to
distribute and that has a lot of equity
implication we can get those to rural
areas different countries with less
infrastructure
so so that's kind of like the big draw
here
predicting the future is more of an art
than a science especially when it comes
to global crises
almost no one would have guessed that
we'd have several working vaccines for a
coronavirus within a year
so it's impossible to say exactly what
role challenge trials will play moving
forward
but if there's anything that we've
learned from the pandemic it's that the
question of which path is the more
ethical one
often doesn't have an obvious answer the
other thing about challenge trials i'll
save because i don't want to
dismiss them i'm not trying to dismiss
their importance is
if we get to a safer way to do challenge
trials
then i think then i'm all in favor of
using them
once they're safer communities broadly
would need to understand what that's
about and
and basically endorse it which is part
of the recommendations from the who and
others
but if if they're safer such that we're
not asking people to take those risks
i think they could be really important
tool in the toolbox and
just as we do them now in malaria trials
they're a tool in the toolbox but
they're not the whole story
you